[Musique]
Trierer les
brebis évaluer leur état de
santé ou encore parer des
onglons en cette matinée hivernale ils
sont une trentaine à tenter de devenir
le meilleur jeune berger d'île-defance
parmi eux une quinzaine de la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet et pour la
première fois cette année une quinzaine
du centre de formation agricole la
Bretonnière en scèemar ça fait une
expérience en plus et ça me permet
d'apprendre aussi les moutons parce que
je suis pas du tout dans le milieu voilà
ça permet d'apprendre et ça fait une
bonne journée c'est convivial les
éleveurs sont assez patients ils
prennent le temps aussi ils ont
conscience aussi qu'on est voilà qu'on
est jeune qu'on est là aussi pour
apprendre donc ils sont très pédagogues
prennent le temps d'évaluer de de voir
un peu aussi notre risence avec la
manipulation de l'animal mais aussi de
pouvoir expliquer nos connaissances donc
c'est très intéressant et c'est une très
bonne expérience et pour devenir le
meilleur jeune berger d'île-de-fance il
faut réussir les épreuves théorique et
pratique ces dernières sont directement
inspirées des gestes quotidiens des
éleveurs vous avez l'état
d'engraissement des agneaux donc c'est
une épreuve importante puisque c'est on
juge l'état des annaux avant des vendre
donc c'est le revenu de l'éleveur le tri
des des brebis bah c'est c'est pareil
c'est une épruve d'éleveurin donc trier
des brobilles selon ce qu'on demande la
génétique c'est pour le choix des
reproducteurs donc c'est pareil c'est
pour leurevenenue puis améliorer la
qualité de l'élevage et la santé animale
bah c'est le B àas de tous les jours
mais ces ovinièdes ont avant tout pour
objectif de susciter des vocations chez
la jeune génération la filière recrute
dans tous les domaines c'est une vitrine
pour notre métier ça permet de de
montrer que notre filière est dynamique
et que des jeunes s'intéressent encore à
l'élevage au vin ça mobilise les jeunes
ça permet de se rencontrer et et
vraiment pour les jeunes ça ouvre plein
de portes ça permet de de rencontrer du
monde de trouver potentiellement de
l'emploi des metttres de stage et cetera
des formations adaptées et ce travail
sur le long terme commence à porter ses
fruits selon le recensement général
agricole de 2020 le départ de 500
éleveurs est compensé par 500
installations chaque année soit un
départ pour une arrivée prochaine étape
pour ces olympiades 2024 la finale
nationale au salon de l'agriculture le
24 février Alexia hurtevent et Amélie
lamperrière auront la chance de
concourir au titre de me jeune berger de
France